we're going to find a side first and
then a table side first and then illegal
so let's keep this guy off good morning
all right we're going to kick off just
one write out the formula I always begin
by doing that not because as you said
before not because it deserves some
bucks just by say that but because it
helps me get my next steps rice good
morning so I'm finding a sigh so i'm
going to write my sine rule in this form
I put the side on the top because then i
just have less rearranging to do on my
subsequent lines okay once I've got my
formula down I'm fitting things into the
right spots right so I've got this X is
what i want and opposite angle is 31
degrees and i put that into my diagram
right x or slide 31 I match that up then
I say I've got my other pair of pieces
of information which is for magically
its opposite angle 73 ok so that's going
to be this and from here like it's
pretty straightforward really you're
going to rearrange put that side 31 on
the right hand side and you're going to
go to your calculator okay so what are
we getting for our actual consult give
me two wonderful place yeah Tiffany so
to point to point to and that's
approximately
I do a sense check does it look like
it's a reasonable number based on the
diagram we've got yeah it does right be
your angle bigger side smaller April's
false ID checks out okay great we move
on to number two and because I'm trying
to find an angle this time I'll put the
angle at the top again slowly to
minimize the amount of rearrangement
that I have to do okay so I'm starting
like this save real different clothes I
could see here I've got the same kind of
setup right so I'm going to go straight
to see leader is the angle I'm after
doing the matching side which is 21 then
I've got sign 78 over here and 36 is
what has you want it okay so we're
getting here and this time I will ask
for that intermediate life can someone
give you the calculator readout on 21
sign 78 degrees divided by 36 yeah but
5705 thank you okay see you ready good
um it is it is valuable to put at least
a handful of decimal you don't have to
put down every secret one but enough to
share without a shadow of a doubt that
you've done this correctly you
understand where this comes from or what
number pops out so now we could reach
her feet up okay now we'll do the
approximation like we could do it fairly
quickly we want it to the nearest
bitters right so when you do sine
inverse let's have a go
if your calculators like mine it's going
to first head you a decimal right it's
going to hear your decimal we want it to
the nearest bitter so you want to reach
for that button is at the bottom left of
the great ones the one that looks like
this and what does that do what does it
do it converts two degrees and then
minutes and in seconds in fact some
calculators even have a slightly
different button degrees minutes seconds
and you guys know how many minutes are
there in a degree 60 and how many
seconds are there in a minute 60 so this
button doesn't just do angle conversions
it also does time conversions because
the conversions we use are completely
identical right so keep that in mind for
the future because whenever you have a
time question and you get some decimals
out you don't have to fuss around you
just hit the button and I'll tell you
that over 15 seconds yeah okay is this
lion necessary I don't think it's
necessary it's no more necessary then on
this line right so so i would put these
two minds at the same category or no if
not required however i think it's
enormously helpful right and the more
steps you have there the less likelihood
that if you make an error you'll not be
able to work out you know my god how
come it's wrong where did I go wrong
right if I had this line down on ok and
if something goes wrong after at least I
can say I got this far and I was
accurate that is something else happen
later so we're getting 30 4.79 yeah that
checks out ok so you hit your degrees of
its seconds button and it gives you this
34 degrees and how many minutes 47 do be
careful after that you've got twenty six
point four five seconds you see that ok
now because there are 60 seconds in a
minute if that number would say 31
minutes then one that's going to round
up isn't it because it's more than
halfway ok thankfully we round down so
I've got this right but this is only one
of the solutions right this is the
ambiguous case so what's the other are
tough but i might get
I'm going to I'm going to take the
supplement right we're going to take
this up a bit so with that number still
by calculator I'm going to go 180 take
away and then our answer is actually
this could someone else someone is yet
145 30 good ok now we pop this down does
it make sense you have a look now we've
already been provided this 78 degrees
and then when you look at this you think
hot on a second this angle here this
angle here isn't going to work is it
right why is it going to work again
eggless on the trouble if I pop this in
here right it's going to be well what is
that like 200 + 220 degrees 32 33
something like that so we've gone over
okay so i would say but the angles I've
already got 78 degrees + 145 degrees and
thirteen minutes what is it actually
equal to is it 223 can someone verify if
I'm stood my head get a calculator I
know it's 200 something so it is 23 and
13 bits right and that's greater than
180 degrees right therefore I could only
get one solution it's only going to this
one theta is approximately can be 34 and
47 okay are you happy with that there's
one more way by the way I appealed I
appealed to the angles of a triangle but
there's something else I could have
noticed okay to remember the whole point
of the side room is big sides big angles
little slides little angles do you
notice there's something else wrong with
this I mean have you noticed that look
at this angle you see it's a huge anal
and I'm saying it should be here but
look it's matching with a smaller side
do you see that right this side is
smaller than this side so this angle
what we saw on this angle right so
alternatively you
you could have said but you know this 21
is less than 36 sophia has to be less
than 78 okay so you've got two ways to
go about